a tragic scene out of the Heartland an
Oklahoma dad arrested for allegedly
fleeing the scene of a rollover crash
that injured some of his family members
and killed his 16-year-old daughter
41-year-old Elliot Benny faces charges
including first-degree manslaughter and
leaving the scene of a crash resulting
in death according to reports officers
responded to the crash on January 11th
in chakota Oklahoma around 9:20 p.m.
officers found 16-year-old Shelby Benny
had been thrown from the car and was
later pronounced dead at the hospital
Witnesses told police Benny was driving
approximately 70 mph and passing
multiple cars in a no passing zone while
it was raining meanwhile one witness
recalled seeing a man standing outside
the family's SUV after the crash when he
asked the man to sit down he reportedly
looked disoriented and ran away
allegedly leaving his daughter to die
police say he fled the scene of the
crash on foot to a family member's home
and switched Vehicles body cam video
from that night captures officers in
pursuit of their suspect there's a phone
ping there the
vehicle they sh the vehicle but I want
to call them
back we have a description
of didn't give a
description they gave me his driver's
license and the tag
SC what's the address on that
standby do when you get a hold of them
up there can you find out there's going
to be damage to the vehicle as
well it moved and it the address that's
paying it looks like to be fly
J 32 clear on route for
Walmart advised over to Flying
J with that vehicle over at fly
J he was found about 50 Mi away from the
scene once police zero in on Benny's
location they have their weapons drawn
officers then demand he get out of the
vehicle hands out the windows
now with your left hand open the
door step out
slowly turn away from
me put hands both up in the air with
your right hand grab the back of the
color of your
shirt grab the C of your shirt P lift
your shirt
up keep
pulling now go ahead and turn slowly
keep
turning keep turning keep
turning stop lower your
shirt take four steps
backwards stop get on your
knees cross your
ankles
stay in that
position
[Applause]
cover officers then go on to search
Benny's vehicle where they make a
disturbing Discovery to vodka another
pip so this is supposed to
open I can't
get hey
I guess we'll just take them place a
ho so he's got several pill bottles in
here and the labels are all ripped
on charges
that
death of one huh fatality fatality
yep weap over
here I got a pocket knife than like
this yeah I got like a pocket knife so
we got marijuana pipes pill bottles with
labels torn and some empty alcohol
bottles of vka after searching the
vehicle officer speak with Benny himself
who can be heard slurring his words when
police briefly question him he man kind
of weapons you have with you pocket KN
okay no guns no other big knives nothing
like that I'm pretty positive okay that
truck's Pretty Dirty there's no telling
what in there but yeah you had your
medical marijuana card I had it okay
it's not I don't have it with me it's in
my wallet I don't know where my wallet
went okay okay well we got EMS come and
check you out okay cuz it's ain't tire
for us all right okay all
right the body cam video ends shortly
after according to reports Benny later
told police he purchased the bottle of
vodka and drank a gulp while driving his
family back home sustained minor
injuries from the crash however his mug
shot shows him with two black eyes
bruising all over his face and cuts on
his lips and nose now what do body cams
like this show you that it's an
unpredictable world right and sometimes
in that world you're going to need a
lawyer but finding the right legal help
is so important and let me take a minute
then to thank attorney Tom and
Associates for sponsoring this body cam
you see whether you were injured in a
car wreck or Refinery explosion or the
victim of security ities fraud or
received a notification that your
information was included in a data
breach developed an illness as a result
of a bad drug or toxic exposure and
there are so many other situations
attorney Tom can help you see what Tom
and his team do so well is they not only
have the legal knowledge of course but
they have genuine empathy for their
clients and having someone you can trust
is invaluable and by the way every call
is free it's private you'll be speaking
with a member of his team straight away
you won't pay a dime until you win which
just shows their commitment to your
success and they have an impressive
track record in tough tough cases and
look if your case is not the best fit
for attorney Tom and his team don't
worry because they still may be able to
recommend you a lawyer because they have
a national network of attorneys they can
refer you to with attorney Tom and his
team you're not just hiring a lawyer
you're getting powerful allies who are
committed to Justice and your well-being
so if you've suffered an injury and you
need legal support click the attorney
tom.com bodycam link pinned in the
comments for a free consultation or dial
855 Tom wz an outpouring of love was
displayed on social media for Benny's
daughter who was killed in the crash on
Facebook Shelby's cheer team posted a
tribute to her saying in part she was a
part of their team for years she was
loved by everyone around her she was a
bright light hardworking and the best
teammate you could ask for we miss her
terribly and please pray for her family
and all the those whose lives she
touched a GoFundMe was created by loved
ones to help with funeral expenses the
author of The GoFundMe wrote in part
quote Shelby's life was tragically taken
away from us and taken into God's hands
she lit up every room she walked into
and never failed to have a smile on her
face her laugh was contagious to all she
was a blessing to a bunch of people and
helped those in need without realizing
it she was someone people could count on
the tragic accident isn't Elliot Benny's
first time dealing with the law
according to two news in Oklahoma he had
an extensive record including three
previous charges for leaving the scene
of an accident those charges were
dismissed in 2010 in 2016 police say
three other people involved in the crash
were treated at a hospital including two
elementary school children and an adult
elot Benny bonded out of jail on a more
than $100,000 bond reporting for long
crime I'm Elizabeth Milner